hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast moisture analysis in Pharma
expanding near-infrared spectroscopy
with Karl Fischer titration I am Judy
Aurora blab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
webcast is presented by lab roots comm
the leading social media site to science
professionals and sponsored by Metro USA
Metro offers a complete line of
analytical laboratory and process
systems for titration ion chromatography
electrochemistry and spectroscopy from
routine moisture analysis to
sophisticated anion and cation
quantification they are ready to help
you develop your method and configure
the optimum system with your analysis
from the lab to the production line with
their custom process analyzers for more
information please visit www.flexsim.com
in the lower right hand corner of the
slide window if you can't hear or see
this presentation properly let us know
by clicking on the support button on the
top right or use the Q&A button we'll
make sure we try to resolve any issues
this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the CD button at the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credits now let's get right
to today's presenters we are proud to
welcome Joseph Head and dr. Keith Friel
Joe graduated with a BS in environmental
chemistry from the College of
environment environmental science and
forestry in Syracuse and then later
completed in MS in analytical chemistry
from Northeastern Illinois after moving
to Chicago
Joe joy met Rome from UOP Honeywell in
2013 after spending 13 years in the R&D
lab as a big metal fan prior to that Joe
worked as a Quality Assurance and
validation chemist and environmental
standards in Pennsylvania
dr. Keith reel is an application
specialist from Metro USA systems in
Laurel Maryland his undergraduate and
graduate work in both engineering and
spectroscopy combined with this time at
Metro USA has seasoned him with over a
decade of experience in spectroscopy in
his role with Metro he performs nir
feasibility studies develops qualitative
and quantitative models needs NIR
training courses and supports met Ron's
partners with their specific application
is the go-to person for chemometrics and
nir method development I will now turn
it over to Joe for his presentation okay
well good morning everyone
obviously this morning we're going to
introduce how moisture analysis is used
in the pharmaceutical industry and in
doing so first we're going to discuss
some specific parameters in Carl Fischer
analysis those are being technique
selection sample preparation and any
automation that can improve the
precision and then Keith is going to
take over and provide an intro to NIR
and it's used as an added tool as well
as introduced some specific NIR
applications so first and foremost why
do we care and where do we find this
moisture and it is found actually across
the entire process through the various
stages from raw materials to the final
product and in this presentation we're
going to discuss some of the ways to
handle some of the different matrices
that you're going to potentially
encounter throughout the process so
again why do we care about moisture how
does moisture affect the pharmaceutical
industry well first of all waters origin
can be indicative of your process
quality control its its presence can
support microbial growth which obviously
is undesired and it can be it can serve
as an easy purity check to confirm api's
if the product is dry you know you're
paying for the active ingredient rather
than water on top of that crystallinity
dissolution permeation these are all
affected by water levels so the
effectiveness
the product is is is affected by water
and so is the stability not only during
the manufacturing process itself but
shelf-life can also be impacted by how
much water is present so let's talk
about how that water is present in
pharmaceuticals generally there are two
main types you've got free water which
is what's available to two chemical
reactions and that's also what's
generally important in stability and
then you've got your immobile or your
bound water which despite the fact that
it varies and how strongly it is bounded
to the product it's not necessarily
available for chemical reactions but it
does affect absorption and effectiveness
of your product so with that
introduction how do we go about
measuring moisture well we've got three
main very prevalent techniques the first
is the gravimetric this is kind of like
loss on drying this tends to be rather
slow rather tedious and it also tends to
have fairly low accuracy it's it's not
selective to specifically water and it
can suffer when you're talking about
very low water levels so moving on we've
got the spectroscopic methods which
Keith will actually be introducing to
you these are very attractive because
they are reagent free analysis and it's
also very very rapid
however this this analysis is a
secondary technique which means that it
needs the third the tight Romaric
technique to standardize it so tighter
metric is what I'll be discussing this
is the Carl Fisher reaction and this is
what can be optimized across the entire
board depending on what sample matrix
you have and white moisture levels
you're looking for
so discussing that technique let's talk
about the chemistry involved the Karl
Fischer titration is what's commonly
used across the board this is a very
specific reaction to just water so what
happens in this reaction is first some
of your reagent the sulfite the base and
the methanol will react and create an
alkyl sulfite intermediate this happens
before you even add your sample then
that intermediate will react with the
iodine added and the water that you've
also introduced and consumed the iodine
to create this iodide and again it's a 1
mole to 1 mole reaction so if you know
how much iodine was consumed you know
how much water you had so this is a
typical Karl Fischer reaction both
curves on the left and on the right are
the same sample what you're looking at
essentially is you're monitoring the
Karl Fischer reaction by measuring the
conductivity of yourself it's known as a
by potentiometric technique so you've
got a double Platinum pin electrode with
a current passed over it and what you're
measuring is the voltage if there's lots
of water present that voltage is very
high when you've got a slight excess of
iodine that voltage drops it's a known
reagent we know our electrodes so we
know exactly what voltage we should be
looking at once the reaction completes
so what you're looking at on the left
hand side here is this blue this blue
line and I'm going to write in red this
blue line happens very rapidly at first
what you're looking at is volume against
time so you're adding your titrant which
contains the iodine very quickly and the
reason you're adding it
very quickly quickly if you look over on
the right the corresponding voltage is
very very high which means there's lots
of water present then what happens over
here on the left is you start seeing
these spikes what that means is once it
adds a dose of the titrant initially
there's some excess iodine before it
gets consumed that kind of indicates
that hey I'm getting close to the
endpoint the instrument recognizes if
you're close to the endpoint I better
slow down that titration rate and kind
of level off and Plateau and then when
you can get that drift down below 250
millivolts you know that you now have
your excess iodine you know that the
drift is stable you know that the
reaction is complete and at that point
the titration is complete it finds the
endpoint tells you how much iodine was
consumed and calculates how much water
you have in your sample so there are two
types of ways that we can do this this
analysis the first is volumetric
titration now volumetric titration is
very good for what we consider higher
levels of moisture that's a tenth of a
percent or a thousand ppm all the way up
to one hundred percent water so our
solution are our solvent is primarily
methanol and that we're titrating with
an iodine reagent so we're actually
adding the iodine from an external
source and in that reaction we're also
bringing in the sulfite and the base so
that we can create that intermediate the
benefit of volumetric titration is it
tends to be very very fast you're
getting results in just a few minutes
it's also applicable to all sample
matrices whether they be solids liquids
or gas
and again because of that is a very
modifiable system meaning you can you
can add solvent you can add buffers you
can add other types of reagents to aid
in the titration and I will be actually
talking about that in just a few slides
so bear with me but before we get to
that I'd like to also introduce the
other style of Karl Fischer titration
which is kula metric kula metric is for
typically lower levels of moisture down
to 10 ppm up to about a percent now if
you notice that there's a little bit of
overlap between kula metric and
volumetric between a thousand ppm and 1%
and that's okay if your samples fall in
that range then you get a chance to
decide which application is best suited
for you and that's going to depend on
how you want to handle the sample what
sample size you have what matrix it is
and we can determine what would be the
best route now what sets
kula metric different from volumetric is
that the iodine rather being added in
from externally it's actually being
created right in the cell from iodide
that's already in your your solvent so
what we have again is two electrodes
we've got you're indicating electrode
and this is just like it is in
volumetric and that's determining
whether or not you have that excess
iodine but then you have this generating
electrode and the purpose of this is
actually to make your iodine titrant
you're actually applying a current and
you're analytically converting that
iodide to iodine when you're indicating
electrode senses that hey I've got a
little excess here that's what tells the
generating electrode shut off that
current you're done you've made enough
and we know the the based on the current
applied and how long we apply that for
we can calculate very precisely how much
iodine was produced and if we know that
and then again we know how much water
was in your sample so now that we've
discussed both the volumetric in the
kula metric we'll look at more in the
chemistry and what can happen to that
chemistry based on the types of samples
you have so first and foremost the Karl
Fischer reaction really likes to occur
at a pH range of about 5 to 7 in that
range the reaction occurs essentially
normally completely and reliably if you
have samples it's going to push that pH
to the lower level to more acidic then
what happens is the chemistry just
cannot occur very very efficiently and
you get a very slow very sluggish
titration and poor results same time if
your samples end up pushing the pH into
the higher range into the basic realm
then that ends up actually can creating
some side reactions which again is going
to bias your results and not give you
quality data so it's important to stay
right in that pH range why do I bring
that up why is that important well as a
couple of case studies in one particular
Parkinson's treatment we used active
ingredient
benzy reside hydrochloride this is a
nitrogen containing compound which will
increase the pH another substance in in
topical antiseptics Pro valine Hemi
sulfate it also increases pH value so
what do we do when we have these samples
that we know that we introduce sensitive
cell they're going to drive the pH into
the high range and potentially cause
issues we have to actually buffer that
cell and we can use either the salicylic
or the benzoic we add that ahead of time
let it stabilize let it condition and
now we can add our samples knowing that
with a buffered solution we're going to
hold that
pH right where it needs to and get good
results and for volumetric we can use
either salicylic or benzoic for kula
metric we recommend benzoic only because
of how the salicylic actually can react
with the generating electrode which
again any kind of side reactions are is
is not beneficial so moving on what else
do we have to be concerned with beyond
pH well there are a number of side
reactions that can interfere with the
chemistry we can have reducing agents
that actually can consume that iodine
create iodide and you're going to get
bias results you can have aldehydes that
are going to consume the sulfite and
react with that and that interferes with
the ability of the chemistry to occur
you can have acids and bases as we just
talked about where they're interfering
is actually they're consumed they're
reacting with the base that we already
have in the chemistry which is why we
have to buffer the system for those we
have aldehydes we have ketones we have
assets we have cylon all these can all
react with the alcohol and create side
reactions so what do we do in that case
well in that case again we have to alter
the alcohol in some way so to prevent
those those reactions from happening and
then finally kind of everything else we
have oxidizing agents hydroxides
carbonates they can consume the iodide
on the opposite end and either shift the
equilibrium or create excess iodine
which is going to bias the results so
it's essentially what we're trying to
get at is it's very very important to
have a good understanding of what your
sample matrix is and what you have in
your sample to know ahead of time how it
might react with the chemistry and then
if you know that ahead of time then you
can take steps to alter your your
analysis to to get good results
and we were talking about essentially
side reactions how do you recognize a
side reaction how do you know it's even
occurring well in this craft we have a
comparison of a good reaction to a side
reaction the blue is a good titration
water is consumed very rapidly as we
showed in a couple of slides prior once
you start seeing that excess iodine the
titration slows down it plateaus over it
gets a stable drift and it stops so what
you generally see with a side reaction
is again the water tight rates quickly
and then it senses that it's close to
the endpoint so it'll start to Plitt all
over as if it's going to stop but then
rather than finding that stable drift it
kind of tight rates at a slower rate and
that and it just kind of drifts on out
into eternity and that long slow drift
we're never quite finds an endpoint and
goes for a long period of time that's
indicative of a side reaction so again
what do we do about side reactions well
there are a lot of chemistry that goes
into handling side reactions but what's
the best thing we can do
how about take anything that causes side
reactions completely out of the equation
if you've got stuff in your sample
matrix that can cause a problem
don't put that matrix in the cell you
still want to measure moisture how do we
get just the moisture into the cell and
out of the matrix that's why we have an
oven technique this is very similar to a
headspace analyzer
you've got the sample filled in a vial
and it's heated in the oven that heat
drives the moisture off of the sample
and then that moisture is carried by a
dry gas from your sample over into the
titration cell where the cell actually
ends up seeing just the moisture and it
and your sample stays in the vial out of
the chemistry and out of any possibility
of creating issues this this technique
can be used for either volumetric or
kula metric
analysis and the important part of this
technique is choosing a temperature
where the water is going to be
effectively efficiently and completely
released without being so high that
you're decomposing the sample and
getting degradation products which again
can either cause side reactions or
create water so here's an example where
we're analyzing morphine hydrochloride
and we know that the sample will melt at
200 degrees so in this case we've chosen
the analytical temperature as a hundred
and eighty degrees and at a hundred and
eighty degrees we release the water very
rapidly and completely but we don't get
to a temperature where we're going to
start to melt the sample and get any
kind of degradation so what you're
seeing here again the red is the actual
titration and the water is released very
rapidly initially and then once it gets
to the end of counter will plateau over
and come to a nice stable drift and once
it can hold that drift and it gets the
last little bit of moisture out that's
when it says hey I'm done now the blue
is actually the drift that it's
measuring while it's going that it's you
know if you have high drift obviously
that means water is coming out rapidly
and the one interesting thing is if you
look at the blue you see essentially
three distinct Peaks right that
indicates actually that your product is
trihydrate so at one hundred and eighty
degrees you've broken all the bonds for
the trihydrate you've gotten off all the
water you you get the the last few
hundred seconds the last couple of
minutes is just with the residual
moisture in completing the titration and
then it says it's done so in that case
it was pretty easy
hey we knew what the melting point is
what if we don't know how to handle the
sample well in that case we
can use a temperature gradient as we did
for this this product here the madam is
old sodium what we did is we gradually
ramped temperature over time while
measuring the water content so if you
look here at the x-axis
we've got temperature from 50 to 250 and
that corresponds to the time of 0 to
6,000 seconds and we've got water coming
off so what happens again is the water
comes off quickly and then it comes over
in a plateaus and everywhere between
about 1,500 seconds all the way up to
about 5,000 seconds no real new water is
coming off and then after that once we
get up around 200 and over 220 degrees
we get the second plug of water that
comes off well it's generally expected
that's probably where the sample starts
to degrade and that's that that would be
a degradation product that would be
water that you're not concerned with so
you want to choose a temperature
somewhere in that plateau after all the
water has come off but before the sample
degrades and that's why we chose right
in the middle of that plateau 150
degrees so that's how the the oven works
what are some other preparation
techniques for shall we say special
samples
first of all Lisle iced cakes
lyophilization has had success in
preserving and storing vaccines
microbial cultures and other biological
products right and it helps maintain
their integrity better than either
freezing or preservatives but how do we
how do we handle those for moisture
analysis because generally they're they
tend to be very hygroscopic removing
them from a vial in in the atmosphere is
not ideal and solubility is kind of a
challenge as well so what we might
suggest is performing an extraction so
you inject a small amount of conditioned
methanol into that vial then you found a
Kate if necessary you you ensure that
the sample is fully dissolved and then
you would transfer that aliquot of
methanol into a Karl Fischer cell to
measure the moisture that's that's one
way to go about it what's another way to
handle de lisle ice products that would
be the use again of our Karl Fischer
oven this way you don't have to perform
extractions you don't have to ensure
that you have dry solvent and you can
minimize sample handling worst case
scenario you're transferring that sample
into a sealed vial in a glovebox to
minimize any atmospheric moisture and in
some cases you can even remove that step
by customizing your sample rack or the
oven block to use the sample vial sizes
that your Lisle izing your product in
and this is just this table just in
indication of the range of sample vials
that we can actually accommodate and
customize our instrument to to accept so
what are some other benefits of Karl
Fischer using the oven technique I mean
we've already demonstrated that you can
use that technique to avoid side
reactions and we've demonstrated that we
can use it to analyze problematic
matrices that otherwise wouldn't react
when directly injecting into a cell on
top of that it also reduces your manual
sample preparation you don't have to
extract it you don't have to dissolve it
you don't have to manipulate it simply
put it on a tray it increases throughput
because again because of the sample
changer you can now multitask you set up
a row of 20 samples you walk away and
find something else to do you're
increasing precision because now you're
ensuring that every sample
handled exactly the same and because of
these reasons you it's not limited to
just these difficult samples you can
actually use anything that gives up the
moisture upon heating in a beneficial
way using the oven so but again taking a
step back what else can we use
besides the oven well again the key to
any sample analysis is solubility you
chemistry needs to have access to the
water to effectively titrate it and that
means that we have to have access to
both free and bound water in the sample
so how do we get that water to be
available to the reaction we can use
either homogeneous we can use Koh
solvents or by temperature we actually
are heating the titration vessel itself
so again going back to the Koh solvents
and the homogenous Asian say you have a
solid tablet and you need to get that
into solution if you drop it in this
tablet is going to be bouncing around
and it's only going to get the surface
off surface water not what's inside so
well if you crush the sample up in a
mortar and pestle ahead of time you're
exposing it to a ton of atmospheric
moisture that's not going to give you an
accurate reading and in some cases even
cutting the sample up is going to still
expose it to what it's not typically
used to seeing you're breaking that
coating and you may get an
unrepresentative sample so in that case
like I said homogenize ation is ideal
because you're integrating the
homogenizer right into the sample vessel
where the reaction is happening so all
you have to do is drop the entire tablet
with no sample preparation into the cell
then the homogenizers job is essentially
like a blender it's going to completely
obliterate that tablet to break it up
get it all into the solution and allow
it to react with the Karl Fischer type
raishin and we have different different
ways to do that we can have an aggregate
with knives or we can have just
essentially a pulverizing blender where
it draws the sample up and grinds it up
and then even further we've got kind of
a table aggregate on steroids which if
you've got really tough coatings is much
more robust at just smashing these
tablets up to nothing
another benefit of the homogenizer is
you can actually integrate that into
automation in this case you'd weigh the
sample into the beaker that beakers is
sealed with aluminum foil and then the
titration head comes over it drops down
breaks the foil and seals onto the top
of the of the sample vessel with an a
thick o ring it'll automatically add
solvent which you've already determined
the blank on ahead of time as I said the
Honda homogenizer will obliterate the
sample mix it well with the the solvent
and automatically titrate so you can
program the homogenous Asian depending
on your sample matrix you can use
whatever speed or whatever time is
necessary to completely mix whatever
sample you happen to put on so as kind
of again another case study we can show
we used this automated technique for 10
different types of tablets of varying
moisture levels and we ran them multiple
times so the first row shows the average
moisture content for each set tablet
type second row shows the ballpark
expected moisture levels for each sample
type and then we have standard deviation
and relative standard deviation
indicating that not only are we getting
mean water levels that are pretty close
to expected but there were getting very
good precision
from sample to sample now it is an
interesting point out that we did we did
a just sample size in to correlate with
moist expected moisture level so as a
for instance tablet type 2 we would use
one single small tablet
whereas tablet style type 1 we might use
three or four or five tablets to get
enough sample to get a good titration
the other thing to note is all of these
are at least approximately one percent
or higher this is obviously this is
volumetric titration so we're you were
using this for higher moisture contents
or expected water levels so in
conclusion I've kind of introduced the
Karl Fischer reaction how you can adjust
it to your your your sample matrix and a
couple of different of preparation
techniques handle different types of
samples so you've seen that it's a very
adaptable technique for pretty much
moisture right down from ppm up to
percent level in various matrices not
only that as I said before depending on
your matrix you may use a co solvent you
may use modulation you might use other
preparation techniques to ensure that
you're getting a good number and
specifically the oven its benefits as
far as reducing side reactions being
able to get to found water and to get
good repeatability and what I'm going to
do at this point is now that I've I've
covered the more tight row metric
methods I'm going to let Keith take over
and he's going to expand on how NIR can
actually be used as an additional tool
to to handle moisture okay thank you and
now we're gonna as Jill mentioned switch
gears over to the NIR spectroscopy
portion of the presentation and as Joe
mentioned in the introduction near for
spectroscopy is a secondary technique
and can be a excellent technology to
implement when high throughput analysis
is desired
so really the overall goal here is to
use the NIR spectroscopy as a tool for
rapid analysis to make predictions of
your primary KF value so I'll described
in this coming slides how this is done
and then give a few examples before that
just a general overview of spectroscopy
spectroscopy in general is the study of
the interaction of light with matter so
in a spectroscopy experiment the light
from the light source is sent into or
through the sample the light that's not
absorbed by the sample can then be
separated spatially into the individual
wavelengths so the end result of any
spectroscopy experiment is to then
determine the amount of light that's
absorbed at each wavelength using a
detector so the spectrum or graph shown
here is that absorption spectrum of the
light absorbance on the y-axis as a
function of each individual wavelength
on the x axis so the peak positions or
the absorbance Peaks on the x axis can
give you important qualitative
information like material identification
or product qualification and the value
on the y axis can give you important
quantitative information such as what's
the individual component concentrations
like moisture content so in spectroscopy
a spectrum can give you different types
of information depending on the energy
of the light that you're using first the
spectroscopy experiment and you can see
the near infrared region here on these
total electromagnetic spectrum is in
between the UV vis region and the mid IR
region so depending on the energy of the
light you can get back different types
of information you might be familiar
with UV this spectroscopy in this case
the light is interacting with electrons
in your sample so you can get important
electronic information if you
on the other side of the nir region
you're in the mid IL region and here
light is interacting with molecular
vibrations as you can see in the
animation here these molecular stretches
and bends and this type of interaction
with vibrations can give you important
information because those absorbance
Peaks are related to the different types
of stretches and bends so it can give
you important chemical information about
what types of Bund you have in your
sample and how much of that material is
present the near infrared region is also
interacting with these same types of
vibrations
it's just present as overtones or
combinations so this might be the same
type of stretch or bend multiplied or
different combinations of these
fundamental bands that you see in the
mid iron so near-infrared spectroscopy
is then considered a vibrational
spectroscopy technique because you're
looking at these same types of modes and
the peaks and the NIR spectrum originate
from these types of vibrations so the
more specifically getting into what
types of stretches or what types of
bonds absorb in the near infrared region
anything with a OS or NH or CH or sh
bond is going to have a significant
absorption in the NIR region for example
shown in this spectrum this is a
spectrum of water and you can see the
peaks originating from the O H stretches
at 1450 or 1959 a meters so it's these
bonds that are present that gives rise
to these peaks and depending on how much
water is there or how much moisture
present in your sample those Peaks will
increase or decrease depending on the
concentration so as far as using
near-infrared you might be asking why
should I use near-infrared as opposed to
other technologies that were described
previously each technique is going to
have its own advantages and
disadvantages one of the big advantages
of near earth red specifically is that
it's a high-throughput technique you can
get results in less than 30 seconds so
this can really help to save when you
start looking at labor costs or reagents
or solvent costs because it's a really
rapid technique also the training is
really minimal in order to set up your
method and validate your instrument and
validate your methods the manager
training would would be involved for
that which could take about three days
but in order to run a spectrum you don't
need a trained chemist operator really
only needs about three minutes of
training because you just show them how
to take the sample which could be in a
vial or a plastic bag even place it on
the instrument and press the acquire
button and thirty seconds later you have
to have your answer
it's so it's that simple also it's
applicable to process environment as
well there are process instrumentation
that can give you real-time results in
the process and by having the fast rapid
measurements you can get results every
20 or 30 seconds and monitor trends in
time for example monitoring a dryer you
can take competitive measurements and
monitor the material right in process
without having to do any sample
preparation or anything or take a sample
out also you can read environmental
goals since there's no reagents and no
sample prep no solvents no waste it's
just light and your sample and that can
be attractive in a lot of different
areas beyond just moisture and outfit
your thread can be used for other types
of analysis both qualitative and
quantitative for example in qualitative
analysis you can use Mira red for
material identification so incoming raw
materials or a final product
qualification is possible by IR by
taking the spectrum of the product or
material and comparing it to a library
of pre-qualified materials also for
quantitative analysis which I'll focus
on in the coming slides this is taking
the absorbance values
and correlating to them to some type of
concentration of individual components
and as I mentioned before trend analysis
is popular by monitoring either these
qualitative or quantitative values in
time and being able to monitor these
quickly getting values every 20 or 30
seconds can be really important for
optimizing your process and even using
those values for process control as was
brought up earlier near-infrared is the
secondary technique so I'll get a little
bit more into how the NIR
instrumentation or methods are developed
using primary methods such as Karl
Fischer titration so more specific to
moisture analysis these are the steps
that would be involved in building a NIR
calibration model or developing a method
to be used for near fed spectroscopy as
a rapid technique the first step is to
collect samples these would be your own
samples that have a variety of moisture
levels so you'd have a low moisture
level a high moisture level and several
in between you first analyze those with
the NIR spectroscopy done since the
method is non-destructive you can take
those same samples and analyze them by
Karl Fischer titration then you'll use
the software vision to build your
regression equation and the purpose here
is to correlate any spectral changes to
the changes in moisture that you
determine from Karl Fischer titration
and once you have that method developed
and validated then you can apply that
model for rapid analysis using an IR
spectroscopy so let's get into some
examples the first is Wi-Fi live samples
so here you have live live samples in a
vial in a glass vial we collected
several different moisture values in
that first step took the NIR spectra
took the Karl Fischer titration of the
same samples
then built a model of the Sackler and
were able to implement NIR as a high
throughput method resulting in
significant cost savings so here's the
calibration set so this is what the
system manager would develop collecting
these calibration samples with various
concentrations of moisture so there's
about 10 samples are so used here and
what you see here is the multi vial
analyzer you just take all those samples
in the vials place them on the tray
close the lid and press the acquire
button and it will monitor or take the
NIR measurements of each individual
sample automatically so the the sample
presentation and analysis is really
straightforward and easy to do here's
the results this is showing the spectra
of all the different samples compared to
the spectrum of water so that you can
see where in the spectrum the absorption
of water is so you can see a change in
that region 1950 or 1250 going from a
low concentration that would give you a
little lower absorbance value up to the
highest concentration of water with a
higher absorbance in those regions so
this is what you really want to see in
building a quantitative model you want
to see a larger response in the an IR
spectrum that correlates very nicely to
the change in moisture so for each of
these samples we then did the Karl
Fischer titration and we're able to
assign to each absorbance value a coffee
sure or moisture value using the NIR
data and KF data we then developed an
equation which is shown at the top this
is just a linear equation correlating
that absorbance value to the NIR
predicted moisture the blue dots on this
graph showed the ni our predicted value
for this regression equation on the y
axis compared to the actual CAF value on
the x axis so anything on this diagonal
would indicate a perfect model at the
zero air
of course you're always going to have
some error maybe it's from overlapping
differences in the spectra or spectral
variation or non-optimized model maybe
you can go back and make improvements
but a lot of times it's going to be
related to your primary methods so any
any error in your primary method such as
your Carl Fischer titration is going to
be inherent in your NIR calibrations so
when you're optimizing these NIR model's
you want to make it so that your air
reflected in our predictions is as close
as possible to the error that you're
getting from your primary method so in
this case the error was very low and
very close to what you'd expect for Karl
Fischer titration and then the next step
is then to take that model and apply it
to samples that were not used for the
calibration and that's what you see with
the red dots here so these are
completely independent samples analyzed
by NIR then analyzed by KF and the error
prediction here was only about 0.12
percent so this is a way of validating
your model saying that if you take a
sample within this range of moisture run
it on the NIR within 30 seconds you can
get your moisture value with an error of
0.12 percent so the high
but analysis really enables you to do
100% final product qualification and
this is one example showing laughs alive
samples taken at random 40 different
samples showing that some of the
products here actually had a high
moisture due to degradation or
contamination which makes them a low
quality product so being able to do the
hundred percent final product
qualification here is really necessary
because taking one out and testing as a
batch might not be able to identify
these failed individual samples as I
mentioned previously and IR is popular
for process analysis this is the same
type of technology using the an IR
spectroscopy instrument on the left
instead of placing your sample under the
instrument you actually have probes that
are placed in line and then connected to
the instrument using fiber optics so you
can have up to nine different probes
coming off of one instrument going right
into your process and whether you're
monitoring solids or liquids or even
gases you can have different probes
suitable for your sample type this next
application is showing the in line
analysis and a fluid red granulation so
in a fluid bed you have your material
loaded into the granulator and that air
is is pushing it up and making it as if
it's flowing in the fluid bed granulator
then you have your spray phase where
you're adding in a binding solution that
turns the powder into granules then
after it's the right particle size or
the right type of granule you shut you
stop the flow of the fluid and then you
start a drying phase so then the
moisture level starts going down so
being able to control this process and
have the best control of this process
requires some type of in process
analysis and air fraud will be used for
this
so you can see the probe inserted right
into the fluid by granulator on the
right this is the scoop probe which has
a scoop at the end so the sample which
is fluidized lands on to the probe
itself for a measurement then right
after the measurement a puff of air
blows that sample off and allows the
next sample to be on so that you're not
analyzing the same material and over
it's a good representative sample of
what's in the fluid bed and you can see
the process analyze it right in the
center there that would be connected to
the probe by the fiber optics here the
spectra from a variety of different
batches of the granulation and you can
see in the 1950 region again the change
in the absorbance value there which
increases as the moisture increases so
again we're using the software to
correlate these changes to samples that
were taken out with a sample thief and
analyzed by Karl Fischer titration we
get the same type of results here on the
left you're showing the calibration
values the IR predictions compared to
the actual moisture values and you have
a really good correlation here based on
the spectral changes being able to
predict the moisture level in a fluid
bed then in order to test it this is a
validation in the middle you
we ran several other batches and took
samples out to the spectrum at the same
time made a prediction based on our
model of the moisture and then compared
it to the lab value and had really good
accuracy the standard error of the
prediction here was about 0.3 percent so
this is showing even within the process
even in a tough environment like a fluid
that you can do accurate sampling get a
good spectrum and make accurate
predictions of moisture to a 10.3% and
this is showing a one full process going
from the beginning where you load the
material
adding in overtime you add in the
binding solution which increases the
moisture in the fluid but once you get
to a certain level the moisture for the
the fluid is stopped and then you enter
the drying phase and you can see the
moisture starting to go down and then
you reach a level where you have your
optimal or ideal moisture and shut the
process off so being able to monitor the
moisture in real time can really give
you some great control over your process
and be able to help reduce over
processing or under processing and be
able to have more information about
what's happening in your system as I
mentioned before nirs and use just for
moisture it can be also be used for
other chemical or physical properties
and this slide shows in addition to
moisture we actually did particle size
so this is monitoring the particle size
within the fluid that granulator and you
can see during the spraying phase the
particles are increasing in size and it
kind of stabilizes there once the food
the fluid is shut off there's a small
drop of a particle size due to moisture
being lost and the particles tending to
compress a little bit you can see the
overall particle size increases
throughout the process and the advantage
here is that not only can you monitor
moisture but you can also monitor these
different chemical or physical
properties in real time simultaneously
so for once once 30-second spectrum you
can monitor multiple different
parameters at the same time so just to
before we get to our question-and-answer
coffee shirt which still remains the
kind of gold standard because of its
specificity for moisture and is the most
used for the wide variety of
pharmaceutical ingredients and finished
products when they had high throughput
or non-destructive method is desired and
IR can nir spectroscopy can be an
excellent complement to your payout
value giving you the accuracy that is
comparable to the KA of titration it's
also very precise which allows you to
run at your trends right in process and
do qualitative or quantitative analysis
of different components and as I
mentioned in during the talks that IR
can be used either in the lab
environment or approach can be placed
right in your process and monitoring and
process in real time and so thanks
everybody for attending and I'll switch
it over now to the Q&A session excellent
presentation thank you for bringing that
information to us before we get started
with all of your questions use a quick
reminder about how to reach us today
questions can be sent via the green to
an a button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll get to as many
as we can and so our first questions can
moisture and gas you measured by KF or
NIR so I'll take the first portion of
this moisture can be analyzed in in gas
met room actually does have a KF gas
analyzer it does take a little bit of
extra handling but essentially what you
you do is you care a cylinder or a gas
source you pass it through a heated
expansion valve to ensure that
everything is in the gas phase phase and
then you monitor the bubbling through
the Carl Fisher cell all moisture is
tight
and then when you're when it's complete
you either use like I said a mass flow
controller to calculate how much gas is
passed through or simply by weight by
again tarrying the the cylinder to see
what the weight of the gas that was that
was analyzed
so in that case obviously you your your
your you have to use a pretty
significant sample size if you're going
to measure the weight of gas but then
again typically in gas you're looking at
very very low moisture levels so and
I'll let Keith take take the NIR portion
of the question
yes our process instrument you have a
gas cell that you could do gas an ALICE
and it really depends on a lot of
factors like the pressures or
temperatures or even the concentration
of moisture that's in the gas but it can
be possible in the right conditions and
we're always happy to get more
information to find out more specifics
about the application to see if it'll
work and your next one is from Martin he
says stability samples get to be tacky
so he asks will the homogenizer handle
this so to kind of qualify that question
I'd like to tentatively say yes but what
typically you need to look at for tanky
samples is first of all the the
solubility in the Carl Fisher matrix and
how you're quantitatively transferring
the sample sample into the cell what we
know is from Carl Fischer systems that
we have in actually the food industry
we've done several tacky samples we've
used Carl Fischer to analyze gummy bears
hard candies such as Jolly Rogers dried
fruit caramel so obviously we can very
very easily do
tacky samples and the homogenizer can
grind that up this is one we would use
to aggregate with the knives to kind of
cut that up but what you'd want to do as
well is optimize that solution so when
you are mixing it up you actually have a
solution that's amenable to keeping that
that that blended sample in solution or
obviously the other situation is if you
can transfer that sample into a vial
that might be an ideal application for
the Carl Fisher oven hey Kenneth from
ethnics Deafness products company asks
do you need to have a model for each
different product I think it depends on
on how different the product is it a
good test is to just run the spectra of
the two different products and if
there's a significant difference yes
you'd have to build a different model
for each product so collecting the
different moisture values for each
individual product if the products are
chemically similar and the spektr don't
look too different you might be able to
get away with bundling a variety or
several different products into one
model but using your proper validation
procedures may be building one model
from one product and testing it against
another product and validating it should
be enough to answer that question has
been from inter gel pharmaceuticals asks
what is the best method to measure
moisture in a soft gel capsule so I see
a soft gel capsule probably the
homogenizer it would be my guess because
once you've broken the the outer layer
of the capsule the the inside is going
to disperse pretty easily so obviously
if you're trying to put that capsule
into an oven then moisture has to
migrate through the liquid filling
through the coating and then out if
you're trying to do direct injection
that's not ideal because you drop the
capsule
you have to dissolve it so that would be
one situation where a homogenizer would
work work very well you could take a
capsule drop it in the knives are going
to chop chop up that sample break that
coating and allow the liquid Center to
disperse and mix well with the solvent
and and titrate fairly rapidly and just
to add on to that once you have your
your primary method in order if you
needed a rapid measurement we also have
the lab instruments for tablet or
capsule analysis that will do
reflectance or transmission measurements
to determine moisture and other
component concentrations Teresa from
BASF asks what is the practical
quantification limit for water using NIR
an example show lowest value of about 1%
yeah that example is kind of on the high
end of the limits of detection I think
in an ideal environment you could get
down to hundreds of ppm just because
moisture is a really strong absorber in
the NIR region it's not going to be
ultra trace you're not going to get down
to like one or 10 ppm levels but
hundreds of ppm is certainly possible
meet them at the University of Kentucky
asks can I use KF commission moisture
concede say biological material and do I
need heaps keeps gap method indirect
method or can I use the C direct to the
titration system so obviously this would
take a little bit of Investigation
personally I'm not familiar with the
heat scape method but I do know that you
most likely you would be able to analyze
moisture directly in in your biological
material and again I'm going to sound
like a broken record it really boils
down to fundamentally knowing the matrix
and being able to guess if there are any
side side reactions possible seeds for
instance if it's
if it's a if it's a bound water and you
can most likely use the oven at fairly
low temperatures and then you would
replace the gas instead of pumping dry
air you could pump dry nitrogen and that
would prevent any kind of charring or
pyrolysis and then you could just simply
dry the feed carry over any available
moisture and titrate that and in some
cases you may even again depending on
what the sample is direct injection may
work where the methanol will extract the
water out of the sample and titrate it
directly homogenizer may be applicable
but I would think that at using Carl
Fischer for for that product would be
would be applicable thank you
we have run out of time so if we didn't
get your question today we will follow
up with you via email I would once again
like to thank Joseph had and dr. Keith
feel for their presentations do you have
any final comments for us today
no thank you a lot and thank you
everybody for attending yeah I would
just like to again repeat Keith and
thank everyone for for attending today's
presentation okay well I would like to
thank our speakers today Joseph head and
dr. Keith Friel as well as our sponsor
Mitchell USA for making it possible to
bring this presentation to you today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through June 2016 you'll receive
an email from us alerting you when it's
available on demand and posted on
lappers calm you're welcome to forward
this announcement to any colleagues who
weren't able to join in today thanks for
logging on and participating in today's
broadcast we'll see you next time